carpal tunnel syndrome occurs
when a narrow area around the
wrist known as the carpal tunnel
swells and presses on the median nerve that
passes through it over time this
can lead to progressive numbness,
tingling and weakness
where the median nerve sends  its
branches to the palm and fingers of
the affected hand carpal tunnel
syndrome usually affects
those who have jobs
that require repeating the
exact same forceful movements with the
wrist over and over again it can also
be caused by  of
wrist injuries rheumatoid arthritis or
hormonal or metabolic changes a
tough band of tissue called the
transverse carpal ligament
runs along the length of the wrist
forming the roof of the carpal tunnel carpal tunnel
release is a
surgical procedure in
which the carpal tunnel is cut  band and
nerve pressure is released, relieving this
As symptoms of
carpal tunnel
syndrome arrive at the hospital
for surgery an intravenous line will be placed
and you may be
offered medication to help
you relax carpal tunnel release
may be performed under
general anesthesia which will  keep you asleep
for the duration of the operation with a
regional nerve block that will
keep you numb from the shoulder
down or with a local anesthetic that
will keep the wrist area
completely numb an
uncomplicated carpal tunnel release
usually takes 30 to  90
minutes
there are two ways to perform the surgery
in the traditional open procedure
the surgeon will first make a single
incision in the palm and wrist
the surgeon will then separate the
underlying tissues until reaching the
transverse carpal ligament and cut
it thus creating more space for the
median nerve
a newer and minimally  The
invasive technique requires only two small
keyhole incisions
or punctures instead of a single
relatively large incision the
purpose of this technique is to make the
recovery period shorter and
less painful the procedure begins
when the surgeon uses
cutting instruments called  trocars to
make two small holes or
ports in the wrist and palm of the
hand
the surgeon will then insert a
fiberoptic device through the
port in the wrist the
camera images are magnified and projected on a
monitor located  in the operating room
using instruments passed
through the other port
the surgeon will cut the
transverse carpal ligament at the completion
of either procedure the
wounds are sutured
after surgery
your wrist and forearm will be splint-fitted
and transferred  to the
post-surgical recovery area for monitoring if
necessary  you will be given
pain relievers since carpal tunnel release
is an
outpatient procedure most patients
are discharged within a few hours you
will need to arrange for a
family member or friend to drive you home